So as Lorenzo mentioned, there are two qualities to the central nervous system
that influence introversion and extroversion. And these two qualities are
cortical arousal levels and sensory threshold levels. For example, by cortical
arousal, we mean how much the brain is active at rest. And some people, while
at rest, not being stimulated, their brain is really quite active. And coupled
with that often, is a low sensory threshold. Meaning for these people, it
doesn't take much stimulation to arouse them. And we call these people who have
this pattern introverts. And introverts are often regulating their behavior in
order to optimize their arousal level. So they withdraw from people they don't
know. They tend to avoid real sensory experiences like parachuting and roller
coaster rides, and jumping off cliffs into water. So on the other hand we see
the opposite pattern in extroverts, and in extroverts we have low cortical
arousal and high sensory threshold. Meaning that at rest the brain activity of
extroverts is relatively low in activity. And coupled with that is a high
sensory threshold, meaning it takes more stimulation to arouse extroverts. So
they regulate their behavior and arousal levels by seeking out stimulation.
They really want to be around people, around noisy environments. Do thrill
seeking and risky kinds of things like parachuting and roller coaster riding
and jumping off cliffs. So you may or may not have noticed that, in fact, we
filmed these two different scenes, talking about introversion and extroversion
in different environments. So when we were talking about in introverts, we were
in a white background room. And now we're in a room with more colors and
there's more going on. This was not a coincidence because as it turns out
introverts tend to feel more comfortable in, in rooms and environments where
there's less going on. And extroverts tend to feel more comfortable in rooms
and environments where there's more going on.